buonasera ancora provate a pensare tutti
quanti per un attimo a un progetto che
avete realizzato e di cui vi siete
sentiti orgogliosi
non importa una cosa grande e una cosa
piccola una cosa media l'importante che
abbiate pensato a questo abbiate
riflettuto
sviluppato la vostra idea compiuto
diversi passaggi alla fine sia arrivati
a una fine
non so se ci avete fatto caso ma molto
spesso quando parliamo di realizzare i
nostri progetti utilizziamo termini come
avvicinarsi alla meta può
camminare
un passo dopo l'altro
mettere un piede davanti all'altro anche
usare le proprie gambe inteso come
farcela con le proprie abilità sembra
quindi che il camminare questa attività
lenta e ripetitiva sempre uguale ci
porti ad avvicinarsi a raggiungere i
nostri sogni
qui è dove il mio camminare in giro per
il mondo e in diversi laboratori sparsi
in continenti
lungo tutto il pianeta mi ha portato
oggi al baio design lab dell'università
di hardware realizziamo esoscheletri
composti da tessuti indossabili che
possano aiutare le persone a camminare
esoscheletro questo parola tecnica
significa appunto scheletro esterno
e come potete vedere da la nostra slide
qui abbiamo uno dei test che svolgiamo
all'interno del laboratorio studiamo
come le persone camminano studiamo il
movimento delle persone per riuscire a
disegnare questi strumenti che appunto
aiutano le persone a camminare dobbiamo
avere una conoscenza del nostro tipo di
cammino
questa è
la nostra il nostro scheletro è composto
da tessuti indossabili vedete nelle foto
di destra si mette veramente come un
paio di pantaloni è una tuta e
grazie a due motori che vedete attaccati
al fianco allo zaino collegati a dei
cavi alle gambe riesce appunto a fare sì
che la persona
possa andare in giro grazie a un aiuto
esterno il sistema è veramente composto
semplicemente da pantaloni motori e cavi
lo zaino che vedete li essere stato
semplicemente uno strumento per
attaccare appunto i pantaloni e nel caso
vuoto il sistema stesso e dotato di
sensori intelligenti che riescono a
capire i vari eventi del ciclo del passo
riescono quindi a capire se la mia gamba
sta atterrando
oppure se la mia gamba in fase di spinta
e in base a questo praticamente non
fanno altro che fornire la corretta
spinta alle persone che hanno bisogno
potete intuire che l'applicazione di
questi sistemi è enorme e tutte le
persone che hanno bisogno di avere
quella che in gergo si chiama una
camminata aumentata possono beneficiare
di questi sistemi
pensate persone con mobilità ridotta
persone che hanno avuto una emiparesi
una paresi anziani
persone per esempio che devono
trasportare grossi carichi appunto nella
fotografia vedete questo zaino perché
stavano svolgendo un esperimento di
questo tipo
potrebbero essere
forze dell'ordine quindi soldati
potrebbero essere escursionisti e
qualsiasi altra persona che voi possiate
pensare abbia bisogno di una camminata
aumentata il
la possibilità di realizzare
una camminata aumentata è stato uno dei
sogni dell'umanità da anni ed anni se
tanto per citare un esempio alla fine
del 1800 quindi potete immaginare un
attimo lo stato tecnologico della fine
del 1800 è stato brevettato il primo
esoscheletro di alto inferiore questo
questo nonno diciamo del nostro sistema
arriva
ad oggi a questo che invece riesce a
ridurre l'energia che noi usiamo mentre
camminiamo quindi utilizzando il nostro
sistema che spinge le gambe in sincrono
con il mio movimento riesco a utilizzare
meno dell'energia che normalmente uso
per camminare
ovviamente dal brevetto del 1800 ad oggi
per arrivare ad iron man di strada ce
n'è ancora molta da fare però se
fare in modo che avere una camminata
aumentata sia uno dei sogni dell'umanità
possiamo per caso riuscire a fare il
contrario possiamo fare sì che
siamo capaci di raggiungere i nostri
sogni con le nostre gambe e
quello di cui vi ho parlato adesso è
stato ed è tuttora uno dei miei sogni
poter lavorare in quest'area in questo
laboratorio è riuscire a contribuire a
creare un tipo di strumento che possa
essere di aiuto per moltissime persone
nel mettere insieme
questa presentazione per il ted ho
pensato allora un po agli anni passati e
ho pensato alle cose che mi hanno
ispirato e sono state d'aiuto e durante
il mio percorso durante il mio cammino
fin qui e mi fa piacere
provare a condividerle con voi oggi
attraverso cinque parole che spero che
potranno essere di aiuto ispirazione
anche per altri
la prima per me è la passione
se non c'è la passione non si va da
nessuna parte
mettete passione nelle cose che fate
spendete soprattutto del tempo a capire
veramente
quali sono le vostre passioni
cosa vi piace fare veramente non fatevi
trovare in situazioni pre costituite
preconfezionate in cui siete costretti a
fare quello sempre comunque la stessa
cosa senza avere possibilità di cambiare
strada lungo il vostro cammino
appassionatevi alle cose e cercate altre
persone come voi che siano appassionati
in modo da poter condividere le stesse
passioni
la seconda per me è fatica che poi anche
veramente strettamente collegata alla
prima tanto da essere un po la stessa
cosa
non esiste la possibilità per me di
realizzare un sogno senza
mettere della fatica fatica intesa come
sacrificio voglia e disponibilità di
rinunciare a certe cose per arrivare un
grande obiettivo
la terza e consapevolezza
siate consapevoli
delle vostre abilità delle vostre
capacità le possibilità ma anche e
soprattutto dei vostri limiti
decidete voi dove fissare l'asticella
e poi
dovete solo raggiungerla
la quarta e riflessione soprattutto oggi
in cui bisogna sempre fare fare fare
fare fare un sacco di cose sempre
bisogna fare di tutto penso che sia
molto importante ogni tanto fermarsi a
pensare
non necessariamente a pensare al vostro
obiettivo a quello che dovete fare per
raggiungerlo ma semplicemente fermarsi
un attimo e
riflettere spendendo un po di tempo con
se stessi
se poi avete anche la possibilità di
arrivare fino alla su c'è anche una
bella vista
l'ultima
sono le radici
e penso che molti di voi riconosceranno
questo posto
quel bambino non so se lo riconoscete
però sarei io
e penso che le radici siano molto
importanti
perché dimostrano da dove siete partiti
voi tenete sempre gli occhi fissi dritti
davanti al nostro obiettivo ma con la
coda
guardate dove siete partiti le radici
dimostrano quanta strada avete fatto per
arrivare dove siete oggi
e vi dicono quello che siete veramente
quello che siete diventati la vostra
identità sono le vostre radici
spero che
oggi alla fine di questa giornata
tutti voi possiate uscire da qui dopo
aver ascoltato queste presentazioni
avere visto diverse cose e pensare
veramente a quello che volete fare nella
vita
e magari già oggi fare
il primo passo per realizzarle